Hi, I’m Evan Carmichael and welcome to another edition of Modeling the Masters.
I believe that the fastest and most effective way
to grow your business
is to model the strategies of people who’ve already done what you’re trying to do.
So today we're going to look at how a young man
who couldn't hold down a steady job
and couldn't get his mind off
of thinking about hunting and fishing
turned his passion into a business and would go on to be named
one of the Top Ten Entrepreneurs of the 20th Century by the Wall Street Journal.
This is the story of L.L. Bean
and the top 3 lessons that you can learn from his success.
Leon Leonwood Bean was an inventor
author, outdoor enthusiast, and founder of the company
L.L. Bean
As a young man
Bean couldn't hold a steady job and drifted from place to place.
He would much rather be out hunting and fishing
than working for someone else.
After a series of outdoor expeditions,
Bean returned home with his feet soaking wet
because there wasn't a good shoe that could keep them dry.
He set out to solve the problem by visiting a local cobbler
and creating a new shoe for outdoorsmen.
He called it the Maine Hunting Shoe.
Bean got a list of hunting license holders,
set up shop in his brother's basement
and drafted a letter to be sent by mail to his list.
Bean wrote, "Outside of your gun,
nothing is so important to your outfit as your foot-wear."
You cannot expect success hunting deer or moose
if your feet are not properly dressed."
The letter was a success
and he sold 100 pairs
only to have 90 of them returned because they broke apart.
Bean refunded his customers the money
took out a loan to modify the design and began selling again.
By the time Bean died in 1967
company sales had passed $4 million per year
and the Wall Street Journal named him
one of the Top Ten Entrepreneurs of the 20th Century.
Today, with over $1.7 billion in annual sales,
L.L. Bean remains one of the most
successful family-run businesses in the United States.
By following what excited him and by taking action
LL Bean was able to transform himself from a man
who couldn’t hold down a steady job
into one of the Top Ten Entrepreneurs of the 20th Century.
To help you transform your business
here are 3 Action Items that you can learn from LL Bean.
Action Item #1: Care for Your Customers
If you want people to keep buying from you
and tell their friends to buy as well
you need to care about their well-being
and provide as good an experience as possible for them.
This is especially true in industries where there
isn't really that much that's different between what you're offering
and what your competitor is selling.
The differentiating factor that will make customers
want to buy from you is the customer service
and the experience that you give them.
Bean's name became synonymous with outstanding
customer service.
One of his policies
was the 100% money back guarantee
with no expiration date.
No matter how long ago you bought his products
Bean would refund you all of your money
if you weren't completely satisfied.
He'd even pay for the postage
for you to mail it back to him.
Knowing that his customers were hunters
and fishermen
who often needed equipment
in the middle of the night
Bean also threw away the keys to his store
in Freeport and kept it open 24 hours a day
365 days a year to give them a better experience.
It's only been closed twice in its history.
According to Bean
“No sale is really complete
until the product is worn out
and the customer is satisfied.
A customer is the most important person ever in this office
in person or by mail.
Above all, we wish to avoid having a dissatisfied customer.
We consider our customers a part of our organization,
and we want them to feel free to make any criticism
they see fit in regard to our merchandise or service."
Action Item #2:
Be Your Target Market
One of the best ways to do market research
and really know if you're on to something or not
is to be your own customer.
Does your product or service work as you would like it to?
Would you be willing to pay money for it?
Does it solve a real problem?
The more you're a part of your target market
the better chance you’ll have to create a product
or service that will really sell.
You'll know because it helps make what you're currently doing better
faster
or somehow more effective.
Bean's passion was hunting and fishing.
It's what led him to create the Maine Hunting Shoe
and kept him inspired to continue growing his business.
Whether his executives wanted to launch a new fishing rod
shirt
or tent
Bean insisted on personally testing all of his products
because it had his name on it
and it needed his personal seal of approval.
After the failure of his very first Maine Hunting Shoe
he always took his products out into the real world
to make sure they worked before they were sold
even when his team around him advised
that there were better uses of his time
and someone else could do it.
If it worked for him
he knew his customers
would like it because he was one of them.
Bean once wrote in his catalogue
“It is no longer necessary for you to experiment
with hundreds of flies to determine the few that will catch fish.
We’ve done that experimenting for you.”
Bean continued being a part of his target market
for as long as he could hold a fishing rod
and lace up his boots.
Action Item #3:
Network
Entrepreneurs often aren't great
at promoting themselves and networking.
Many of us are happiest when we're working on a new product
or providing a service
instead of actually getting out there and selling.
But getting your product or service
into the hands of the right people
can often make or break your company
and you need to be an effective networker
to make sure that they know what you've got!
Bean was always an outdoorsman at heart
but he knew how to network and promote his business.
After the avid hunters started buying his products
Bean made a point of connecting with high profile people
to introduce them to his company.
Everyone from Franklin Roosevelt to Babe Ruth
to John Wayne found out about his products and began using them.
Bean also sponsored high profile athletes
like the 1932 Macmillan Arctic Expedition team
who wore his boots on their expedition.
But you didn't have to be famous for Bean
to let you know what he did.
As one local writer from Maine wrote of Bean
“If you drop in to shake his hand
you get home to find his catalogue in your mailbox.”
So remember;
care for your customers
be your target market, and network.
To finish up this video
I wanted to share one of my favorite true stories
about LL Bean and some of his best quotes.
When Bean first threw away the keys to his store
and invited hunters and fishermen to come visit the store
whenever they wanted
he installed a late night bell
to allow people to ring for assistance.
Customers who arrived late at night
would see the bell and a sign that read:
“Push once a minute until clerk appears.”
Pushing the bell would bring a watchman
and often even Bean himself to come help the customer
no matter what time of day it was.
Thank you for joining me for another edition of
Modeling the Masters.
If you liked the video and want to see more
please give it a thumbs-up.
I’d also love to hear your thoughts and feedback
if you want to leave a comment below the video.
And stay tuned for the next episode!
Subtitles by the Amara.org community